Let’s talk in detail about some of these
monadic functions.
First, changing the pixel type—quite useful
frequently to convert an unsigned integer
image into a double image. So what we are
going to do is take input pixels in the range
0 through 255, and these are integers so they
have got value 0, 1, 2, 3 and so on, and we
are going to map them into the range of real
numbers between 0 and 1. And we can represent
that mapping by a graph, which is shown there
on the right.
Conversely, we can convert double precision
images into uint8 images. So what we want
to do now is to take pixels in the range 0
to 1 and map them into integer values, in
the range of 0 to 255, and again we can represent
this mapping graphically. Note that in both
cases, the mapping is a straight line and
it passes through the origin with a gradient of 1.
We could also change the brightness of the
image and there are a couple of ways that
we can do that. One way is simply to add a
constant positive value to all of the grey
values within the scene.
So f(x) is the input value x, plus the value
of 1/4. And if we represent that graphically
we see this shape here, and what happens is
that some of the pixels are going to exceed
the value of 1. So we apply what we call a
saturation: we don’t allow them to be greater
than 1, so our line has got a kink in it.
If we apply this transformation to the Mona
Lisa image we can see that indeed the image
that has become brighter.
Another way to increase the brightness of
the image, often referred to actually as increasing
the contrast of the image, is to multiply
all the grey values by a constant, and in
this case we are going to multiply all the
grey values by the value of 2. We can see
if we represent this graphically again, the
slope of the line now is steeper than it was
before. This line now has got a steepness—a
gradient of—2, and the saturation problem
is more pronounced now.
So there are a lot of values which if we apply
the function to x would have a value much
greater than 1, and we have had to limit those
or saturate those to the maximum value of
1, which we have when we represent images
in double precision numbers.
What we can see now when we look at the image,
we can see that it is indeed much more contrasty,
but we can also see some areas where the pixels have become saturated.
A simple function like this 1-x produces a
negative image. So this is it graphically:
a line with a slope
of -1. And what happens here are bright input
pixels become dark in the output image and
vice versa. I mentioned earlier the technique
called posterization, which you can often
find in pop art. And what we do is we limit
the number of possible output brightness values
that there can be. We quantise it if you like,
so in the image shown here what we have allowed
are only four possible output grey values,
so this staircase mapping converts a continuous
range of input grey levels to one of four
possible output values.